Ok, je vais tenter une nouvelle cascade.
Très périlleuse...
Tourne toi pour qu'on soit de face !
Allez, tourne toi !
*SQUEEZIE tombe*
C'est réussi !
*Douleur* J'ai une énorme bosse.
Aujourd'hui, on se retrouve pour discuter ensemble
découvrir un petit thread Reddit sympa...
D'ailleurs, ça s'appelle pas des threads mais des subreddit.
Voilà, pas du tout des threads...
Et c'est au bout de la 7ème, 8ème vidéo de ce genre qu'on s'en rend compte
Mais c'est, c'est pas grave !
Mieux vaut tard que jamais !
Quel proverbe de loser !
"THE OCHO !"
En référence au film Dodgeball.
C'est un thread sur lequel on retrouve toutes sortes de sports
peu connus, voire, même des fois, un peu obscurs
voire, même un peu inventés de toutes pièces, mais qui sont très marrants.
Je vous avoue qu'étant un grand sportif, quand je suis tombé sur ce thread,
Subreddit !*
ça m'a tout de suite frappé, je me suis dit, il a été créé pour moi.
*rire*
OK, on commence tout de suite avec le record du plus grand hula hoop
Non ! Ne me dites pas que ça, c'est un morceau du cerceau.
Ne me dites pas que le cerceau est si grand qu'il ne rentre pas entièrement dans le champ de la caméra !
C'est parti !
Wouaaahhhh !
C'est hyper impressionnant !
Il faut qu'il fasse au moins trois tours complets consécutifs pour que le record soit validé...
Et que ce soit entre sa taille est ses épaules
Regardez !
Il a un truc scotché autour de lui pour pas qu'il ait mal !
1 ! 2 ! 3 ! 4 !
Il continue pour le plaisir de ses fans !
Il fait plaisir à ses fans !
Il a réussii !
Il peut plus l'arrêter !
Je partage réellement sa joie à premier degré.
Wouaaaaaaaaaaaahhhhhhhhhh !
Mec, alors là, j'ai envie de tout, sauf de me moquer
Là, c'est genre, incroyable !
Hyper impressionnant, j'espère un jour avoir une Gusiness Record, au moins aussi fou !
2ème... Ah ! Ça, c'est un truc de colonie. Une discipline de colonie
Quoiiiiiii ?
On dirait un... Quoiiiiiii ?
Ah ! C'est une course, mais quand t'as pas trop envie de courir...OK !
ça a l'air, à la fois drôle, et à la fois...très chi**t...
Mais ça vous fera passer, de manière sûre et certaine, de bons moments entre amis...
Haha... (Rires jaunes)
Faites-le simplement, à l'abri des yeux du monde entier
Oh ! J'adore ça ! Une course de personnes âgées.
Je trouve ça fou que des personnes âgées soient en meilleure forme et plus fortes que des jeunes. Au même sport qu'eux.
C'est incroyable !
C'est parti ! Faites-nous rêver, on va vivre cette course ensemble.
ça va être plus impressionnant qu'un match de Ligue 1, c'est parti !
Oh ben ! Ils ont raison de couper avant de laisser les autres passer la ligne...On s'en fouuut !
Le premier est tellement épatant !
Mais regardez ça ! Il court plus vite que nous !
Vous ne regarderez plus jamais votre grand-père de la même manière après avoir vu ça !
J'suis épaté !
Est-ce qu'il courait vraiment très vite ou ce sont ses concurrents qui étaient particulièrement lents ?
Alors, on a l'impression qu'il court très vite
Non il nous nique. Non cherchez pas il nous defonce
si vous êtes  comme moi et que vous faites très peu de sport il  nous défonce
Alors ça c'est quoi "butt acrobatics"
Ahh, cest un jeu de mots avec
Butt c'est le c** en américain.
Découvrons cette spécialité ensemble
Non ne me dites pas que c'est non ! *couinement*
Mais rien ne va. Mais c'est fou de faire ça
*couinement*
WOUAH. Mais ça doit faire si MAL !!
WOUAAAAAAAAAAAAHOOOOOOOOOOUUUUUUUUUU !
Attend mec comment il fait juste comment il fait
Il a plus de muscle dans son c** que nous dans nos biceps les amis !
Non mais je suis sérieux. Comment c'est possible
Non mais il y a un délire de glu ou quoi
C'est pas possible bro ! (bro = frère en anglais)
En plus il envoie un pc
Genre c'est hyper lourd regardez !!!
Il se prend un pc dans le c** et il est au calme
C'est incroyable !
J'ai vraiment un respect incroyable pour ces deux gens quoi
C'est des vrais athlètes
Faut vraiment qu'ils soient appréciés à leur juste valeur
Regardez ça en-dessous là. Le concours de corde à sauter au US, là.
Mais c'est beaucoup moins impressionant
Je suis désolé mais il faut admettre les choses
Peut-être qu'il y a des sport qu'on a pas mis en lumière et qui méritaient plus de lumière que d'autre
Il faut se poser les bonnes questions à un moment
Bon la suite
J'adore ce thread
Je suis en train d'aimer profondément ce qu'il se passe
Attend c'est quoi
Un concours de cut au couteau
Q'est ce que que c'est que cette histoire
alors déjà déjà
Helsinki entre deux saisons de la casa de papel
On sait on sait, on sait aussi ce que tu as fait, on t'as vu, on dit rien, promis, promis on garde ça pour nous.
Qu'est ce qu'il faut faire ?
C'est hyper glauque
*en rigolant* Faut couper du saucisson !
WAHOU ! Ça c'est impressionnant WOUAH la précision
Mais mec c'est vraiment impressionnant.
Mais quand il est de dos c'est hyper badant.
Ça fait vraiment très peur.
*musique suspense d'horreur*
Attendez mais c'est hyper impressionnant.
En plus il a l'air gentil regardez le
Ça a l'air d'être un homme gentil, honnête, sympathique comme tout.
C'est le genre de personne quand tu oublies ton porte-monnaie au restaurant
C'est lui qui te le ramène. C'est ce gars là vous voyez
et est ce qu'on va se poser la question du "comment il est arrivé à un tel niveau de maitrise avec un couteau"
Non! Certainement pas!
Ohhh c'est un truc à l'école c'est mignon...
Quel jeu ils faisaient ?
Nous on faisait du volley
Et j'avais très mal à la paume de la main à la fin de chaque séance
Pierre feuille ciseaux...
Ah ok, faut aller de cerceau en cerceau
et y'en a un qui part de l'autre coté et quand tu le rencontres il faut faire un pierre feuille ciseaux
pour pouvoir passer ton chemin
OH NON il a perdu
C'est le meilleur jeu, ça mélange agilité et CHANCE !
Oh elle va y arriver, elle va y arriver, elle va y arriver...
*eh non* NAAAANN
Allez, Allez, vas-y mon grand, vas-y mon grand...
OHHH!
Vas-y champion
*hurle* OH NOOON, Il y était !
Oh non, vous avez vu comme j’étais à fond dedans, si peu de temps
J'suis sur y'en aura d'autres, des sports mélangés comme ça.
ça marche trop parce que y'a le coté skill et vitesse où il faut aller vite
et le coté où tu rencontres des adversaires et faut avoir de la chance pour pouvoir passer ton chemin
Bon après les pros la, qui sont en Ligue 1 du pierre feuille ciseaux me diront
"Mais euh, c'est pas de la chance"
ARRÊTEZ!
Moi je jouais avec le puits, déjà, de base
Donc je fait parti des, des reclus
Ah bah tiens regarde quand on parle du loup
Ice football
Les mecs font du football sur de la glace avec des chaussures de bowling.
Ils ont mixé trois sports
Ils ont prit le pire de chacun de ces sports.
Ils ont prit: Les chaussures du bowling
la glace du hockey sur glace
et le ballon EN MOUSSE! du football.
Le ballon, qu'on déteste tous
ça a donné, le pire sport
Bravo.
*musique épique*
Attend quoi...
QUOOOIIII
QUOOOIIIIIIIIIIIIII ????????!!!!!!
Attendez mais ce mec vient de sauter de la hauteur d'un p***** d'immeuble
Mais moi gros, à sa place je m'enfonce dans le sable et je disparais.
*couinement*
Attend, ça mélange le saut à la perche et le saut en longueur.
Donc t'arrive en courant sur une perche et faut monter le plus possible
Avant qu'elle touche le sol
C'est hyper impressionnant !
Nan mais le mec
attend mais
gros d'où il ne s'est pas pété les jambes.
Regardez derrière le gars il a atterri cent fois moins loin.
Car il tient à la vie!
Comment il s'est pas blessé ?
j'comprends pas
il est chaud le numéro 15.
C'est hyper impressionnant.
World record du lancer d'avions en papier
Mec je me demande jusqu'où il va son avion en papier.
Sachant que logiquement il a juste droit a une feuille A4, comme nous, et ses doigts pour la plier.
Rien d'autre.
*choqué* Nan mais déjà mec ce lancer
*choqué* Wouah !!
Je ne dirai pas ce que je pense mais c'est quand même hyper impressionnant.
Mec, il t'a fait un lancer gros le gymnase n'était presque même pas assez grand
Eh mec j'ai envie de faire un avion en papier et tester
Eh j'ai envie de tester j'vous jure j'vais test.
Eh ça m'a donné envie de ouf.
Je vais refaire ce vieux truc que j'ai fait il y a des années.
Pas en cours, pas en cours hein, j'étais pas ce genre d'élève
*bruissement*
Allez je me concentre
C'est parti !
Ok chui prêt !
C'est l'un des meilleurs que j'ai fait.
Nan, ne sens pas ça.
Oh mais mec !
Mec !
Je vous jure j'ai jamais réussi à en faire des comme ça de toute ma vie.
Mais maintenant ça m'sert plus à rien.
Sauf si mes vidéos font plus de vue, je saurai quoi faire
Qu'est-ce-que c'est que ça ?
Extrême top spinning
Oh, à base de toupies !
Ça va être hyper impressionnant
Ça va être hyper... *rire*
IMPRESSIONNANT !
Voyons voir...
Ah ouais, il doit la lancer sur un petit...
Nan mais mec ! C'est...
Nan mais mec !
Mais ça me tue !
MAIS NAN !
Mais NAAAAAN ! *rires*
En vrai, on va pas se mytho, c'est des années, vraiment où personne te voit comme un gars stylé.
Personne ne te voit comme un gars stylé.
T'es là, comme ça à lancer ton truc
*Heeeee*
T'y arrives une fois sur cent.
Quand t'y arrives pas ça fait un bruit monstrueux, ta femme t’engueule
Mais mec après toutes ces années,
quand t'es capable de réussir à chaque lancer...
La classe que tu as.
Tu arrives à l'entrée d'une boite, t'es refusé: "eh attendez, regardez"
HOP !
Hop la tu rentre !
Mec t'as un passe-partout à partir de là, c'est évident !
*rires nerveux*
Lucas, ne te moque pas et respecte le contenu que tu vas regarder.
Respecte ces gens.
Ne rigole surtout pas...
Mec !
Qu'est ce que c'est que ça ?
C'est un mélange de...
Je sais même pas !
Ok, après plusieurs heures d'analyse.
Bon, plusieurs minutes.
En fait, ils sont tous sur un terrain, en train de jongler.
Quand tu n'as plus assez de quilles pour jongler tu as perdu,
tu es éliminé.
Mais quand t'es en train de jongler, tu as le droit shooter les quilles des opposants.
Pour leur en faire perdre
pour qu’après ils en aient plus et qu'ils soient éliminés en fait.
En tout cas, ce sport connais un énorme succès.
Puisque, les gradins sont remplis.
Oh merde !
Légendaire !
Rock, paper, ciseaux extrême
Qu'est ce que c'est que ça ?
Oh y'a du son !
Pourquoi extrême ? J'ai peur !
*musique suspense*
*Voix en japonais*
Pourquoi il crie ?
On dirait que c'est le héro d'un anime et qu'il est en train de se sacrifier pour son équipe !
Mais je veux ça !
Je veux cet environnement là dès que je fais un pierre feuille ciseaux avec mes amis,
pour décider qui fait la vaisselle !
S'il vous plait !
Eh bien les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo, j’espère qu'elle vous a...
Plu !
Il retombera jamais, cherchez pas.
Vous pouvez attendre longtemps: il retombera pas.
N’hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu !
J'suis très content de ce petit thread Reddit
Honnêtement, c'est hyper divertissant,
et ça montre que y'a des gens qui arrivent a créer des sports avec pas grand chose.
Il n'y a pas besoin des fois de gros moyens pour faire une activité qui est "challengeante", et qui est marrante, même entre potes.
Par exemple, des fois il vous suffit juste d'une paire de fesses et d'un pc portable !
*couinement*
Et c'est parti, on y va !
Peut être pas celle là...
Peut être pas celui là,
celui là j'avoue il est "spé" (abréviation de spécial) quand même.
J’espère que ça aura donné des idées à certains
et pas des mauvaises idées, de bonnes idées.
Je vous invite en tout cas à faire du sport, à pratiquer une activité physique,
c'est important si vous ne voulez pas finir comme moi, et je sais que vous ne voulez pas finir comme moi.
Alors ALLEZ Y !
Je vous dit à bientôt et regardez bien, j'suis hyper chaud, je vais viser l'objectif avec cet avion en papier,
tout simplement parce que je suis un grand sportif très fort.
Oh mec, attend !
Je te jure je le fait jusqu'à que j'y arrive.
AH, P***** !
AH NAN mais c'est dégueulasse !
AH NAN mais nan mais c'est fou là !
P***** !
AHHH !
*léger fracas* YES !!! DU PREMIER COUP !